before we get started with the
presentations we are going to focus a
lot on psychotherapy today and it
occurred to me that we haven't actually
introduced the construct of borderline
personality disorder so I wanted to
review the diagnostic criteria and the
general feeling of what the symptoms are
for the disorder before we get started
this will be really brief this is an
extra hand out in your book it's one of
the sheets that came in it BPD and dsm-5
is very similar to BPD and dsm for its
defined as a pervasive pattern of
relationship self-image and effective
instability and marked impulsivity and
in order to meet criteria in the
diagnostic manual for this disorder you
have to have five of the following
criteria frantic efforts to avoid
abandonment unstable or intense
interpersonal relationships identity
disturbance dangerous impulsivity in at
least two areas recurrent suicidal
behavior gestures threats or
self-mutilation effective instability
due to a March reactivity of mood
chronic feelings of emptiness
inappropriate intense anger or
difficulty controlling anger and or
transient stress-related paranoia or
severe dissociative symptoms you'll hear
the presenters talk about these symptoms
today in different treatments and so you
can refer back to these symptoms when
they're talking about it another way to
think about is that there are really
three core areas of dysfunction
associated with the diagnosis unstable
relationships effective dysregulation
and impulse impulsivity or self-control
BPD is fairly common community studies
have found that it's in one to two
percent of the population and some of
them some studies have shown up to six
percent and in terms of clinical
services that can be ten percent of
outpatients than twenty percent of
impatience I don't want to take up too
much more time I just want to say one
thing when i first started studying
psychology as an undergrad i was
introduced to the concept of BPD and it
was introduced to me as a cut as a
disorder from which people never
recovered they never changed and there
was no treatment and we have come a
really long
away from that and I'm so happy to have
all our speakers here today they're
going to speak to the effective
interventions that we now have for the
disorder and the changes that we see for
people with the disorder so I thank them
all for being here today and with that
I'm going to invite dr. Witter whole to
join me